my name is Rob Cass I'm a professor in
the Department of Statistics in the
machine learning department which is in
the School of Computer Science and in
the center of for the neural basis of
cognition one of the most important
things that can be done to advance
science is to improve methods for
reasoning from data but that's what the
field of Statistics is about and so
that's what I decided to study I was
really a theoretician for the first half
of my career but eventually I went back
to my lab roots and found my butt really
became a true love which is neuroscience
brain related illnesses illnesses
include not only things like
schizophrenia depression autism and
attention deficit disorder but also drug
addiction certain visual impairments
diseases of movements such as
Parkinson's disease and chronic pain to
find really effective treatments for
these illnesses not only pharmacological
interventions but also behavioral
therapies and to differentiate good
performance from bad performance or slow
learning from fast learning we have to
understand the interactions of neural
signals across networks under changing
circumstances an essential part of this
effort is developing ways to say how a
particular set of experimental results
is able to inform us about changes in
neural network connectivity that's the
part I'm interested in that's the part
I'm working on my research has mainly
been about characterizing the way
neurons to represent and transmit
information through their firing
patterns and this has been informed by
firing patterns that are recorded from
experiments by my experimental
colleagues currently my main interest is
in the way neurons work in concert and
networks within and across brain regions
in order to enable a human or animal to
successfully carry out a task like
reaching to pick up a cup or in the case
of a rodent to poke his nose through a
hole in order to get a piece of food as
a reward the technology for this has
been advancing rapidly and the number of
neurons that can be recorded
simultaneously has been growing
exponentially fast these kinds of
experiments can generate billions of
data points and the number of
theoretically possible network
interactions is immense so it's really
essential for any description of brain
network activity to be able to handle
complexity and also to include
statistical assessment of reliability my
colleagues and I have recently devised a
statistical framework
for protecting against false discovery
that works well in a key setting where
the connectivity across neurons depends
on known measured factors such as the
distance they are apart we very much
want to exploit the inside we've gained
in that context too we hope build a
comprehensive set of methods for
analysis of brain connectivity under
changing conditions
you